attention très bonne nouvelle en ce
début de vidéo un ballon gonflé pour la
vidéo daltonisme est encore gonflé après
plusieurs mois
newsmanagers bonne nouvelle finalement
on est là pourquoi aujourd'hui pour une
raison très simple pour la suite des
photomontages l'anr fin d'année bien
résisté marine avait rigolé tout sur son
blog je pense qu'un jour je vais devenir
un beauf s'en rendre compte et je serai
comme ça naturellement je vous ai twitté
de nouvelles photos de moi sur fond vert
le but étant bien sûr de retirer la
couleur verte de m'incruster où vous le
souhaitez pour que ça ait du sens le
démontage cool et propre c'est parce que
j'ai vu là
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça si vous n'avez pas faire
un montage photo n'en fait pas les amis
il faut pas vouloir passer dans une
vidéo à tout prix au point pourquoi
c'est un peu nul a toujours toujours n'a
pas fait un truc nul en fait il y a
tellement de photomontages de qualité
genre level 1 que c'est dur de trouver
ce qu'ils sont bien mais bon qu'est ce
que vous avez fait avec tout ça c'est
mardi et mais dans toutes les vidéos
vous me caler avec des titans c'est un
truc de ouf et dans toutes les vidéos
vous avez du mal à retirer la couleur
verte je n'avais pas vu la première fois
que j'ai vu le film c'est pas à aller à
un problème de proportions roquois que
quoique finalement peut-être que je fais
là la taille de la patte de ce lieu on
n'est pas à l'abri
ok suivante dragon ball squeeze une
petite bd jamais rêvé de qui est là
squeeze je dois supprimés sur youtube
heures qui pervertit nos jeunes ok nomex
te plaît albatar c'est pas mal
et personne n'achètera ma bd si ces
délais surgissent comme sac à dos dans
laquelle le plus possible pour qu'il le
voit ps je l' ai jamais vu aussi
déterminées cd que parce que la
résolution de la photo est dégueulasse
mais obtient qu'un café un jeu wii
squeeze trouver les 8 squeeze caché
sympathique sa très bonne idée une
petite faute au new york times
on en a un qui est là et qui met un coup
de poing à mcdonald's ce vilain clown
qui théorisent des enfants monein cayla
ambiance posé seins qui tombent inquiet
assis aux gestes sans l'air c'est plus
simple puisqu'il ya personne en l'air à
part moi finalement hockey en arles à
pitre accueilli chez le fatah au oui
bien il nous en reste deux à trouver ok
là ils volent le dernier il est ou non
ses origines côtes se trouvent pas
dernier mec safran ses pions y en a huit
sa sauce d'un troll y en a sept je serai
pas pervers à ce point-là loones 8 en
train de courir sur la route [ __ ] été
dur à voir cela voilà squeeze montage ça
s'est bien passé de ça ça fait plaisir
quand je vois ça j'aime internet c'est
trop valeur village et un gros fan trop
de créativité ans est ok une deuxième bd
j'ai mis deux heures pour faire cette bd
je compte sur vous pour qu'ils puissent
la voir cela te rappelle quelques
souvenirs non c'est à mon tour de jouer
dégage je vois déjà où tu veux en venir
une vieille histoire j'ai raconté dans
une vieille vidéo non pas maintenant je
termine ma partie dofus de vata il a
parfaitement débrancher l'ordinateur non
tu n'avais pas le droit à je tapais dans
un cadre à l aller 1-4 de cyprien paf et
grosses ambulance tu l'as si bien
reconstituée à l'aide d'imagés c'est
comme les bon ok je me confesse j'avoue
sondés expliquent des fois il ya des
trucs un peu nul genre les inspecteurs
qui raconte un truc et pour pas que ce
juste un mec qui parle pendant 30
minutes en face caméra il reconstitue
les scènes hockey bref là où je veux en
venir c'est que tu reconstitue aussi
bien que les scènes bilan envoie ton
sévère netflix
jeu de cette différence iphone ok ok
mexes et choses encore pires que le truc
new york en mai dont j'avais pas vu
c'est juste que ça c'est pas du tout la
même personne excellent merci à tous à
temps elle avait la même poste que moi
sur une des photos la regarde elles sont
comme ça juste elle elle ouvre sa jupe
un donc je trouve ça plus sexy suis bon
je ne sais pas faire de montage mais
j'ai quand même réussi à mettre la photo
dans l'autre je suis fatigué de ces
âneries
j'ai dis âneries un amour qui durera
éternellement aa c'est mignon à arrêter
vous me saouler à remettre du tricot
j'ai envie de chialer mes croquettes ou
la vie [ __ ] c'est tellement fait que
les moyens du bord c'est beau la pire
faute au jumbo la main c'est un héros de
gimont on sent qu'il n'y avait pas les
compétences requises pour faire un
montage mais que ça c'est quand même
battu et ça ça me fait plaisir
squeeze montage allez je rajoute une
après les cathos de tout précédent une
photo extrait du fort boyard de samedi
avec squeeze alors c'est pas exactement
passé comme ça
parce que oui j'ai fait fort boyard ça a
été diffusée samedi dernier et je peux
vous dire que ma grand-mère morissette
elle était très aux très très heureuse
et anecdotes attention parce qu'ils
aient la vidéo de l'anecdote c'est fou
juste avant de tourner l'émission
j'étais avec texte présente les amours
et je me suis dit bon les amoureux ce
gars assez les gens d'un certain âge
donc je vois une photo de moi avec tex à
ma grand mère mais je sais pas si le
connaissez ou pas elle me répond je
viens jo cornu skil garder j'ai encore
le script génial regarde avec qui je
suis on à l'hôtel à côté du fort ma
grand-mère a répondu quelle surprise
il va pouvoir aider moralement j'ai hâte
de voir comment ça va se passer bisous à
vous deux j'ai appris plus tard que ma
grand-mère a cru que sur la photo texte
était en fait mon frère j'ai beaucoup ri
j'étais aussi très triste en me disant
mais mam et des yeux vous bien qu un
squeeze surprend sa figurine en train de
faire des avances à max telle horreur à
philadelphie là des fois il a besoin
d'une petite correction ce bâtard la
dernière fois que j'ai pris l'avion j'ai
regardé par le hublot et j'ai vu ça on
en est là ça je serai pas le faire par
exemple quand même d'un bel effort mais
c'est quand même pas drôle c'est triste
mais dans ce que tu veux à sarcelles
news fait de moi même mec sur la scène
qui est obligé de m'envoyer un nude
c'est grâce à toi c'est fou en ce nul
est une bonne blague alors que l'échec
du coup vers la planète celle de taille
[Musique]
on est vraiment là et puis ça de faire
des constructions avec mon corps ça va
pas si je suis gênée elle vous avez un
délai que le royaume était pas de me
caler dans [ __ ] j'ai inventé un
nouveau type de sport aéronautique make
si je pouvais avoir un ironman
domestique comme ça est monté dessus
comme tu montes sur un cheval ce serait
fou attention regardez bien voilà
maintenant vous allez me dire ça
heureusement si quelqu'un a rigolé tu
t'es juste trompé de vidéo mais selon ce
journal est l'exemple parfait d'un
montage nul aimez vous avez un délire là
me mettre dans des groupe uc et pop la
[ __ ] c'est quoi ça encore
on est là [ __ ] c'est pas mal pour les
fuir comme la peste ces [ __ ] là le
kkl et la wii à ses troisièmes qui me
fait bien rire tâche devrait payer ces
gens là pour qu'ils fassent ça tous les
jours je serai vraiment bonne humeur à
four doux le temps mais arrêtez de faire
des constructions avec mon corps oh
[ __ ] il est fou bien joué très beau
mais très belle rêve un peu s'il ya
denis on ne peut qu'aimer en une colo
squeeze n'ont laissé mon anus en dehors
de ça si vous voulez qu est ce que je
viens de dire [ __ ]
[Musique]
ça n'a aucun sens et j'ai perdu des
conditions le café ça vdm mais ça va pas
mais qu'est ce qui se passe là c'est
depuis que nine gars que vous a dit kim
fait des choses comme ça moi oui le sens
trop bonne idée cet intervalle record
des trucs comme plus drôle voilà c'est
pas grave ça pussycat n'était pas
l'aimer comme d'habitude c'était le
deuxième et dernier épisode de ces
images photos font vert pourquoi c'est
la dernière parce que la prochaine fois
on le fera avec des vidéos sur fond vert
je mette un fond vert et je pouvais
faire des petites vidéos et ensuite on
aura définitivement terminée et aussi si
vous savez pas faire de montage photo
vous forcez pas ne fait pas un truc en
plus j'en ai vu plein faire un truc nul
et dire au même que c'était nul ne fait
pas ça parce que du coup en fait même si
ça part d'une bonne intention je vous
assure que du coup le ressenti sur ce
tournage je perds trop de temps à trier
quoi y avoir des trucs nul allez salut
[Musique]